this is the best part last time on TMNT
we compared the way both of these shows
handle their titular heroes as well as
their tumultuous relationships and
casual brushes with bestiality though
seaport one if you have already in
concluding this comparison between the
two takes on our favorite mutated
Terrapin titleholders I need to talk
about their nemesis no superhero is
complete without a good villain to face
and I say in no uncertain terms that the
Shred eliezer is quite a unique foe 2003
shredder wins for the voice acting alone
no this guy's evil laugh is so sadistic
and scary and he sounds so pissed off
with every line with me this is what I'd
imagine Satan to sound like well the
2012 shredder sounds like there is
undoubtedly a fascinating story in how
my old nemesis came to teach ninjutsu
for mutant turtles laser I really only
like Kevin Michael Richardson voice when
he's playing the Joker because he makes
that his own thing otherwise to me he
always sounds like he's doing a Keith
David impression because often he is
2003 version of shredders however a
pretty drastically different take on the
character making him an alien warlord
stranded on earth that's actually just a
little stupid thingy with no hands but
damn is he tough without a body I was
really caught off-guard by this change
while watching this show because I
missed all the episodes handling that
part while I was a kid they basically
merged the two villains from the ad show
and then gave them both the personality
of the shredder from the comics I I
guess what I like about it is that it
gives him a sense of vulnerability when
he's without a robot body he's just a
little angry jellyfish but he has such a
commanding presence and gets so much
loyalty from his henchmen either through
intimidation or
he's earned their respect you don't have
to be the biggest or the scariest to be
a bad guy you just have to be the best
at convincing other Dumber people to be
evil on your behalf
2012 shredder bugs me because he's not
really motivated by conquest or being
pure evil he's just a petty jealous guy
who never really got over his brother
dating the girl that he like he's
devoted pretty much his entire life just
to getting revenge on Hamato Yoshi
aka splinter in this cannon so the
difference is like Darth Vader and
Deathstroke from arrow the girl I like
like she was dead I'm gonna get you
Oliver and I fight is designed far less
appealing but you can't talk about the
complexities of angry gravelly voiced
samurai man without also mentioning his
daughter karai in the older series she's
aware that shredder does morally
questionable [ __ ] all the time this
misery should be put to an end not
prolong presume to question me karai but
she's devoted to him because he was kind
enough to give her a home and raise her
like an actual father would she's
conflicted because she cares about him
but she sees him doing shady bad guy
stuff and isn't quite sure how to deal
with it if it is the Turtles hold them I
wish to destroy them
is something the magical I know nothing
faster a lot of the time this leads to
her playing both sides so everyone wins
where she spares the Turtles or helps
them out but also back Strutters plan
enough that he mostly gets what he wants
this is a really complicated and
interesting dynamic and it makes it all
the more satisfying when she finally
sees that he's too motivated by
bloodlust to let him live blinded you to
the truth father your actions could
destroy us and chooses to help destroy
him once it's wrong CGI karai is
oblivious to the fact that shredders a
scumbag even though he's like well look
at him and has been brainwashed all her
life and her genetic father is actually
Hamato Yoshi he took something from me
so I took something from you so her
weird semi relationship with Leo has
kind of an incest E tone to it that uh
cries our sister sure about that chief
what's with this shows obsession with
testa dean testicles i think her
character arc of betraying shredder
perfectly exemplifies my biggest problem
with the 2012 series the CGI turtle
series is one of the most frustrating ly
slow TV shows I think I've ever watched
it takes 20 episodes for anything to
happen and then it has a chance of being
backpedaled so it takes another 20
episodes to happen for real this time I
feel like a marathoning anime filler
episodes watching this they let us know
who karai is very early on and then
splinter spends several episodes keeping
it to himself that she's his daughter
What's Wrong sensei I learned some
things from the shredder
like what that's for another time
Leonardo karai is my daughter
this time you all knew the truth father
finally then she joins them for one
episode after betraying shredder and
then she's gonna stay with them right No
then she accidentally gets mutated into
a snake monster then they spend like an
entire season trying to find her and
cure her then they just give up on that
shredder finds karai and mind controls
her and then they have to convince her
that he's the evil one all over again
and only then when she's finally able to
just be splinters daughter and join the
team she decides to go start her own
rival ninja clan and leaves it's
irritating because we never get any
payoff for that character relationship
and it takes dozens and dozens of
episodes for her character art to make
any progress only for it to be undone
randomly and then have them working at
it again for a few dozen more episodes I
think it's kind of cool how they
introduced mutant villains as humans
first do a few episodes with them like
that and then wait before changing them
into big monsters that make for good
action figures yet after that character
development for any of these guys is at
a dead halt and they don't do anything
else except whatever shredder tells them
to they might as well be storm troopers
this guy Chris Bradford turns into a
giant dog monster and then later an even
scarier dog monster and he never seemed
to have any reservations about it him
and this fish guy don't make any
attempts to find a cure which does exist
by the way and we'll talk about that
later
and the characters just stagnate
permanently welcome
I will slap you like a salamander I will
feed you like a flounder I will give you
bass to mouth I can't believe he just
said that even the other main bad guys
of the series the kraang usually do the
same plan over and over they just go
somewhere secret build a big portal
teleport in some stuff that'll wreck the
city forcing Turtles to blow it up and
then that happens like six times and
each one is built up slowly over the
course of multiple episodes until they
finally just stop doing it season four
and never come back I guess it's because
they were afraid of this other alien
race called the triceratons which feels
like a flimsy reason given that their
stated to have almost infinite resources
see this show has a problem with
development and repetition there's a
certain kind of status quo that every
villain and hero has to adhere to and
nothing changes unless they build it up
for 40 episodes first and even then they
have a tendency to go back on it for a
bit before fully committing April's dad
is kidnapped for a whole season then
they get him back but instead of making
him a recurring character he gets
mutated and goes missing for another
season before they finally save him then
he just barely shows up ever again
karai being redeemed happens for like
five minutes then she gets mutated and
they spend two seasons trying to get her
back and then she hardly shows up again
shredder spends four seasons attempting
to kill splinter then he does
[Music]
then they undo it with time-travel then
he kills him for real this time in the
same way at the end of the same season
and it's just the feels just don't work
now doing everything important twice
just knocks the wind out of it so while
this show has very satisfying single
episode stories that are fun to watch
one at a time
binge watching it is probably the worst
way to experience it because you'll
start to see how little things ever move
forward
they even abandon multiple storylines
like this goofy friend the turtles have
accidentally mutating into a slime
monster they vow to find a cure for him
and keep him in Donnie's lab he breaks
out once and then they never talk about
it again they even stop putting his
character model in that set they also
established that Donnie can make a cure
for mutants but it takes a long time
okay fair enough
but for some reason he never uses it on
splinter or their friend when he has it
it keeps getting smashed or lost or
given to the wrong person and the show
even forgets to include it after a while
development is astonishingly slow and
there's a lot that just doesn't pay off
although in that same way the 2003 show
is stellar if you don't mind a quick
break from the topic I just want to say
thank you to all the people who started
supporting me on patreon in the last
week or two as I stayed before I'm
having some issues financially right now
and YouTube and my other side job
weren't really going to cut it at this
rate if just 3% of my YouTube subs
donated $1 on patreon every month I'd be
completely sustained and be able to put
more time to videos and pay other
editors to get more stuff out there too
please consider helping me out and I
think we really can meet that goal of 3%
soon thanks everyone
in the 2000s turtles everything is about
development and build up and pay off
when they first fight anything be a
basic ninja
or the shredder or even one-off villains
it's always built up to be one of the
hardest fights they've ever been in they
barely make it they kind of suck but
they keep fighting keep getting better
keep learning new ways to win as they
battle things each time they eventually
learn to beat them with ease it's like
how a boss fight early in the game
becomes a normal enemy later because
you've gotten so much better
they're always leveling up and as a
result they actually win it's so
cathartic to see them succeed once they
beat an enemy force it pretty much stays
beaten they don't just retreat and go
I'll get you next time gadget they beat
the original shredder in season 3 and he
stays gone until a single appearance in
an animated movie set after season 7 and
they kill him in that movie the 2012
turtles always seem to struggle fighting
him as much as they did the first time
and you don't get a sense that they made
any progress hell every enemy seems as
difficult to fight as the first time
even the praying mantis plant guy the oh
three turtles devote plenty of time to
other long-term villains and develop
them over multiple episodes to the show
basically makes these two guys totally
new characters without invalidating
their victory against the first one
they're kind of like hobgoblins to his
green goblin and then they beat these
ones too when the computer-generated
turtles finally beat shredder it feels
empty and frustrating because it took so
long like waiting two hours to get your
food at a restaurant then it's cold by
the time they bring it to you like okay
yeah I was planning on leaving in 10
minutes okay
the o3 show does a wonderful job with
building up long story lines over time
they parse out information for big
reveals piece by piece instead of just
telling you right away and that builds a
sense of intrigue but the show also
makes sure to not go so slowly with it
that you get annoyed and just feel
desperate for answers even the bad guys
all have some forward momentum
Baxter Stockman slowly goes insane over
the course of the series as shredder
abuses him and punishes him more and
more until he's nothing but a brain stem
kept alive by the science that got him
into this mess well as
2012 Stockman turns into a fly but then
they cure him and then he never comes
back and that takes four seasons Bishop
the government agent that distrust
mutants and aliens alike eventually
becomes a hero and has a change of heart
going out of his way to make the world
accommodating to nonhumans after one
saves his life leading to a future
utopia where people from all over the
galaxy coexist in perfect harmony the
2012 Bishop is just a a like a generic
enemy type for like one of these guys
but he's not evil and he doesn't really
do a lot even the stupid nano machine
robot monster that attacks the turtles a
few times has a happy ending where they
help him develop his programming so he
becomes a superhero like a vision
the show starts small in scope and takes
its time to build upon itself so that
dumb crazy giant ideas they fight later
on don't feel random or like a shark job
the 2012 series felt the same way when
it started where the world was at oyster
and it had so much potential for growth
and yet after five seasons it felt like
they were pretty much exactly where they
started just without splinter always
fighting the same handful of bad guys in
the same handful of locations with the
same plot devices my theory is that is
actually a limitation of the CG
animation they have to take time to
model every new environment and
character from scratch so it's cheaper
and more efficient to play with a very
narrow toy box they usually only have
the same group of 20 or so characters
fighting in the city of warehouse
shredders throne room a kraang fortress
or in the sewers a 2003 show isn't
limited by that because with 2d
animation you can really just draw
whatever like just the sky's the limit
sure the animation isn't as smooth but
you can have them go to any location or
fight any bad guy you want
[Music]
that's right I'm actually saying 3d is
harder than 2d animation at at least in
this case I think my favorite episodes
of the 2012 show or when they go to
space and explore different planets for
a while or when they time travel or go
to alternate universes just anything
that's a change of pace one thing's for
sure though no TMNT show is complete
without a crossover with the 80s boys
well check out the initialized belt
buckles on these young right what's up
with the initials on your belts blame I
only wish that during the ladder
crossover that they could have mentioned
the other one even just a hint at it
would have been nice but apparently
there's character rights and licensing
shenanigans and they can't legally
acknowledge this show ever existed at
least they can get the original voice
actors back for realness time I do love
both of these shows both have their own
strengths and do interesting and
different things with the material given
both are valid and really I think the
better one comes down to your own
personal preferences of what the turtles
are do you like a more serious
serialized story or a light-hearted one
with a lot of one-offs do you like the
book that's a parody of grim dark 80s
comics or do you like the goofy and
self-aware colorful romp of the cartoon
my own personal preferences lead me to
saying that I think I prefer the 2003
series more but the later show was also
a blast to watch and I have no ill
feelings towards its flaws one
interpretation is about the adventure in
the journey while the other strength is
in its characters and their bond I think
it's important to remember that there's
no 100% perfect telling of any given
story and that doing a new take with a
different direction doesn't invalidate
the original one's existence
there's no corrective version of the
turtles like there's no correct version
of spider-man whichever one you like
ultimately comes down to what you are
looking for as an individual what they
do differently is what gives them their
strengths I think it's cool how Ninja
Turtle fans that I've observed
don't really play favorites or pick a
side they just love the characters in
any form they take I'm also happy to see
that the rise of the TMNT is so unique
in its own right and it's encouraging to
see a 2d animated series in this day and
age getting such a comically high
animation budget and they say computer
animation is lazy look at this you can't
just open up flashes just do that Mad
Men so let's say that's the fourth in a
row for the win streak of these shows
maybe we can all learn a little from the
turtles and that our differences make us
unique and fighting over which thing is
superior all the time doesn't really
matter no matter how you get the job
done we all love being a turtle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]